près de 500 personnes passent chaque
weekend sur le site de la fenêtre des
Mac un des sites touristiques majeurs de
la Réunion ok je me dis je suis au Mac
mais je ne sais pas ce que j'ai en face
de moi une montagne un paysage
magnifique mais qu'est-ce que c'est que
ce village c'est quoi cette montagne
j'aurais pas pu le décrire seul sans
personne qui m'accompagne et là je vois
que vous avez installé des tableaux
d'indications très très bien fait qui
parle de l'érosion et autres de ces
montagnes plus qui nous donne les noms
des montagnes des villages c'est génial
la dernière tranche des travaux livrés à
1575 mètres d'altitude ce massif
forestier offre une vue imprenable sur
le cirque du silence peut-être un
aménagement qui s'est fait en plusieurs
tranches c'est très long que d'aménager
un site en milieu naturel ça représente
un budget d'environ 300.000 euros
financé par la collectivité cofinancée
par l'Union européenne pourquoi c'est
compliqué c'est long
parce que on doit respecter l'esprit des
lieux parce qu'on intervient dans un
milieu naturel et que on ne peut pas
vraiment reproduire ce que on peut voir
en milieu urbain faut intervenir avec
beaucoup plus de précaution au carrefour
de nombreux sentiers et aires de
pique-nique cette initiative fait partie
d'une dynamique engagée par la
collectivité notamment pour l'accès aux
personnes à mobilité réduite
on l'a encastré dans la dans la barrière
et elle respecte les normes nationales
de d'accessibilité au PMR puisqu'elle
fait 70 cm de haut ce qui permet aux
personnes en fauteuil roulant de pouvoir
scaler en dessous d'avoir la lecture de
la table et en face de le paysage on
explique aussi comment le cirque s'est
formé donc en fait quand on comprend un
paysage quand on comprend un patrimoine
ça permet de se l'approprier et de le
respecter
donc cette dynamique elle s'inscrit dans
quelque chose de global sur le domaine
forestier du conseil général à savoir
réussir à proposer une façon de
découvrir le milieu qui soit nouvelle
qui est l'interprétation grâce à ses
aménagements tout le monde pourra
maintenant profiter de cet espace
naturel et ainsi se l'approprier